hi my name is emily perry and i'm a
scientist
i work at a place called embl ebi which
stands for european molecular biology
laboratory european bioinformatics
institute
that first bit the emble part shows we
are part of a large organization with
lots of different centers in different
countries
the second part ebi is specific to where
i work so let's take a minute to unpick
what that means
firstly we're european which means we're
an international organization
we get funding from all over europe and
we have people working here from all
over the world
there are huge amounts of international
collaborations in science
secondly we're the bioinformatics
institute
what do you think that
bioinformatics means
can you break the word up into parts
teachers you may wish to pause the video
for a moment to discuss
bioinformatics means we study biology
that's the bio part using computers
that's the informatics part
bioinformatics is a great way to do
scientific research without working in a
lab
lab work requires a lot of specialist
equipment and reagents for
bioinformatics you just need a computer
with access to the internet
sometimes we do bioinformatics to help
with lab work
we can use public databases to decide
what to experiment on
and then we do the experiments in the
lab and analyze the results with a
computer however some researchers work
only on bioinformatics creating tools
and databases and analyzing data
to do this kind of work you have to
understand the science behind what
you're studying
but also have the computational skills
like coding to do the analysis
what benefits can you think of for using
computers to research living things
rather than relying on lab experiments
teachers may be paused for a moment to
discuss
things you might have discussed could
include flexibility of when and where
you can work
reducing animal testing
reducing costs of research
saving time and being able to process
and analyze huge amounts of data what we
call big data
you might have come up with your own
ideas too
today today's practical is something
that real scientists would do
we're going to investigate a gene to
find it in new species
researchers might do this to help them
design experiments to do in the lab or
they might have identified a gene from
experiments and want to know more about
it
before we get stuck into the science i'm
going to tell you a little about me how
i ended up in the job i do and what
working for a large science organization
is like
i went to an ordinary comprehensive
school in lancashire
i did sciences for gcse and a level but
i also did a bit of drama
then i went to the university of
edinburgh where i studied genetics then
i stayed on and did a phd
a phd is another degree that you do
after your undergraduate degree
during a phd you work on a long term
research project mine took three years
then write a thesis at the end
for science phds you often do these in a
lab it turns out i'm terrible at lab
work
i am clumsy and i am impatient which are
not good in a lab
but
i did a lot of science communication
stuff alongside it which got me a job
doing science communication in schools
these communication skills got me a job
at embleevi doing outreach which means i
teach and train scientists
how to use the online resource called
ensembl that you're going to be working
with today
i now manage a team doing this which
means my job title is ensemble outreach
project leader
my job is really cool because i get to
work with new and exciting scientific
data so i'm always learning new science
and finding out about the research
that's going on
i also get to travel to research
institutes around the world to teach
courses so i'm always meeting new people
learning about the science they do but
also about their cultures
although i work in bioinformatics i
didn't study it
when i was studying bioinformatics was
quite a new subject
so you couldn't really study it at
university and a lot of a lot of the
skills i need i picked up on the job
this has changed a lot
and now you can study bioinformatics at
undergraduate level or masters
there are even apprenticeship type
programs
part of my job involves working with new
research projects like darwin tree of
life
darwin tree of life aims to sequence
genomes that's full dna codes for every
species in the british isles
we wanted to use this project to let you
know about what's happening with the
darwin tree of life and how the data it
produces helps us to understand
evolution and the different types of
species in the british isles
we also wanted you to see a different
side to scientific research using
computers and if any of you are keen on
computing and science give you a glimpse
of a potential career you might want to
go into
all species on earth came about through
evolution
we all descended from a common ancestor
with different organisms adapting to
different environments and lifestyles
we can see this when we look at the
morphology of different species
comparing the shapes of their bodies and
how they use them
here we can see vertebrate limbs and how
they all evolve from the same bones
but these bones differ in shape and size
to allow them to function in different
ways such as hooves fins or arms
can you see which bones are the same and
how they've changed
teachers let's pause the video and take
a look
morphology is how scientists have
studied evolution for hundreds of years
it was how charles darwin came up with
his theory of evolution by natural
selection
but in the last few decades scientists
have found a new tool for looking at how
species evolve
we can see evolution when we look at the
dna in different species and how the
sequences of genes change
this is where bioinformatics come in
a gene is a sequence of dna in an
organism's genome
the precise order of bases a t g and c
determine the precise order of amino
acids in the protein it codes for
the amino acids allow the protein to
fold into its correct shape and carry
out its function
during evolution the sequence of a gene
and its protein change
genes which started out the same
and diverged or changed over time
between species are called orthologs
for example the gene i worked on during
my phd is called nip bl and is involved
in holding replicated dna together until
it separates at mitosis
it does this in the human cells i was
working with but a lot of what we know
about this gene comes from studying the
orthologue nipped b in fruit fly
the sequence of the gene is similar but
not identical between human and fruit
fly and it does the same job
what uses can you think of for studying
orthologues
we can pause the video here to have a
discussion
we can identify functions of genes by
finding their orthologs in other species
we can study changes over evolutionary
time
we can find functional regions of
proteins
darwin tree of life aims to sequence the
genome of every eukaryotic species in
the british isles
and the surrounding seas
we can find the genes in these genomes
by sampling the rna
when genes are expressed the dna is
copied or transcribed to make signal
molecules called rna
we can sequence the rna then use
sequence matching to map these sequences
onto the genome this tells us where on
the genome the genes are
this can all be done using specially
designed computer software
once we've found the genes we then have
to work out their function and this is
much harder
extensive work by biologists is needed
to carry out experiments to see what a
gene does
this can involve seeing what happens
when the gene is mutated
visualizing where the protein is
expressed and finding what other things
in the cell the protein interacts with
and much more this is very time
consuming
however a lot of work has already been
done
we know the function of most human
protein coding genes
partly by studying them directly and
partly by studying them in orthologs or
the equivalent genes in model organisms
such as mouse yeast and fly
this is down to thousands of scientists
working on this over many decades
orthologs usually do the same job in
different species
both the human gene i worked on nip bl
and its ortholog nipt b in fruit fly are
involved in holding dna together after
it replicates
so if we can find the orthologs of newly
identified genes we can find what they
do
in this way we can use bioinformatics to
drastically reduce the amount of
experiments we need to do
for example i was working on knit bl in
human because someone found that it was
linked to a genetic disease
because we already knew that in the fly
nipped b was involved in holding the dna
in place i could focus my work on
looking at where the dna was held in
cells with this genetic disease
finding orthologs involves matching
sequences
one algorithm that is a computer process
or program that can be used to match
sequences is called blast which stands
for basic local alignment search tool
blast takes a short sequence and tries
to find where in a longer sequence such
as a genome or set of sequences such as
all the genes in the genome it matches
blast assigns scores to matches it can
find and gives the highest score to long
matches with little to no gaps
you can run blast with either protein or
dna sequences
now let's try a practical with this
blast tool
today you'll be using this same website
that researchers use and it is open to
anyone
to use wherever they are in the world
ensemble is a website and database where
researchers can find information
about genes genomes and proteins
well-studied genomes such as human
can be found at ensemble.org
there's loads of extra information on
the genes like what they do what effects
changes in the genes have and where in
the body the genes are expressed
species which are not so well studied
such as the genomes being sequenced as
part of darwin tree of life in a very
new are being put out speedily with
minimal extra information on
rapid.ensemble.org
in this practical you're going to find a
human gene
and export its protein sequence then
you're going to use blast to find the
same gene in some of the darwin tree of
life species
pause the video here and refer to your
worksheet for instructions on this
practical
the sequence of genes and proteins
change incrementally over time
which is what evolution is lots of these
changes put together cause the major
differences we see between species
by comparing related species we can work
out when changes occurred in
evolutionary history
this can help us to categorize newly
identified species
we can also work out when species
diverged and why
we do this by aligning sequences
together
one algorithm that does this is called
clustal
cluster uses similar scoring methods to
blast but it can group together lots of
sequences and say which ones are the
most similar to each other
now let's use clustal in another
practical
we can use the sequences of the human
sea otter black swan and atlantic cod
genes that we found in the last
practical in the next one we need to
export these from ensembl
we will use cluster omega to align these
sequences together
cluster will group sequences based on
similarity and also allow us to see
regions that are common to all the
proteins
pause this video and refer to your
worksheet for instructions
in this activity we've used a real
database that scientists use in their
research
as you saw all the data is publicly
available and can be accessed by anyone
within with a computer and an internet
connection including you
this is called open data and is a
cornerstone of bioinformatics research
we used this database to find a gene in
human that had already been studied
we used the sequence of the human gene
to find the same one in other species
which we know a lot less about
we looked at how these genes are
different to each other and why they are
different
this is the sort of analysis design that
scientists might do before starting to
run experiments
this allows scientists to find out as
much as they can about a gene in just a
few minutes
as a result scientists may be able to
develop cures for disease or contribute
to conservation efforts
if this activity has sparked your
interest you could try investigating
other genes
you'll find lists of human genes on
places like wikipedia that you could
search for
you could also try finding the same
genes in other species that we didn't
look at in these practicals you may be
the first person in the world to explore
these genes
remember you don't need to work in a lab
to be a scientist
bioinformatics is a rapidly growing area
of biology and will be vital in solving
some of the world's biggest challenges
from adapting to climate change to
finding alternatives to oil-based
products con to conserving our most
valuable
and endangered species
if you want to know more about
a career using computers in biology go
to yourgenome.org
or search for a bioinformatics degree at
university